welcome to Episode one of the stronger
by science podcast
I'm your host Eric Trexler and in
Episode one Gregg knuckles and I
discussed the potential link between
creatine and hair loss we also discuss
how knowing about your genetics can
influence your performance and even your
physiology finally I educate Gregg about
how crystals and gems relate to exercise
physiology we end the episode with an
interview with dr. Peter Fijian he's a
pro natural bodybuilder and a scientist
turned coach in the interview we talked
a little bit about research including
his research on hmb and blood flow
restricted training we also discussed
his new book on body building that just
came out a few weeks ago that he wrote
with cliff Wilson so without further ado
please enjoy episode 1 and please come
back in a couple weeks for episode 2
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric drexler your
host if you are not aware of who i am i
am the director of education for
stronger by science I'm a pro natural
bodybuilder I did my PhD in human
movement science and joining me today is
the temporary probationary co-host Greg
knuckles if you don't know who Greg is
he started stronger by science you've
probably seen him at a fitness
conference you've probably seen his
fitness articles on the wet on a number
of websites stronger by science mass and
a whole bunch of others former holder of
world records in powerlifting Greg how
are you doing today doing well and let
me just say since this is the first
episode I truly appreciate the
opportunity to to to get the opportunity
to at least attempt to guest host and
hopefully I don't I don't blow my shot
yeah I'm sure you're gonna do fine I
have a lot of faith in you and since we
record out of your home I thought it
would be fitting to let you join in for
the first episode of it just you know be
tense be nervous don't make any mistakes
and as long as you don't you'll be back
every week until I find somebody
different and likely better of course
yeah so if you're listening you're
probably familiar with stronger by
science and what is math stand for
monthly applications in strength science
strength sport strength sport okay so
Greg and I we write a lot of articles
and now we are venturing into the space
of the audio format a brand new medium
and the podcast is going to give us an
opportunity to make slightly different
content but before we get into how the
podcast is going to be formatted and
what that content looks like I want to
start out with some disclaimer x'
between Greg and I we've got probably at
least six major concussions would you
say at least yeah so so expect some of
that a lot
sentences that begin and kind of trail
off into the ether and never really come
full circle those are going to happen
another thing to keep in mind is that
Gregg and I took an oath to each other
that we weren't going to try too hard
correct and so I think that should set
the stage for what you can expect as a
listener is some minor brain damage
leading to sloppiness and then just some
lack of preparation leading to
additional sloppiness the thing that the
reason we made that oath is when someone
tries really hard and fails it's just
uncomfortable it's you cringe a little
bit and you feel bad and we don't want
to put the listeners through that
correct so as a listener you can at
least have faith that even if it's bad
we didn't try so it's not lame it's
better to have not tried and not failed
than than to try right yeah because
millennial Millennials don't believe in
trying hard everyone is a fool if you
think about it from like a game theory
perspective you have four potential
outcomes either you try hard and you
succeed cool which me nice yeah it's
cool but it's also boring like that's
that's a path many people have trodden
you try hard and you fail that's not
good no one likes that yeah you don't
try and you fail okay that's an expected
outcome sure q you pick yourself up dust
yourself off on to the next one or you
don't try and yet you still succeed now
that's the sweet spot that's that's very
cool that's what we all aspire for yeah
and so that's what we're going for here
yeah now another disclaimer the final
one is Greg you're gonna say something
that's just egregiously offensive I
don't know if it's gonna happen in this
episode I don't know if it'll happen
next episode there's no way we make it
to I'm not gonna keep going on so I was
hoping I could break this news to you at
a time when we weren't in front of
microphones that were recording but like
when I introduce someone to you that I I
care very much of allit I do give them a
warning I say like
it Gregg's probably gonna say something
it's probably gonna be offensive he's a
genuinely great guy with a big heart
now all that we're probably gonna get
100 200 million listeners a week they're
not going to know that about you they're
not going to know that you're a great
guy with a big heart so we're gonna take
care of that episode one Greg doesn't
mean it and another thing he is going to
try to convince you the hard-working
honest listener that I have said
something offensive when I clearly have
it it's his favorite thing to do when
we're in social situations is to expose
me for some BS fake offensive thing I've
said so don't be offended by Greg and
don't believe him when he tries to pin
it on me most things that I say are
meant to be taken sarcastically yeah and
that's the problems we both do that your
way a way more egregious offender than I
am in that regard but but we both do
that so it's gonna be a problem it'll
come up many times we'll get you know
we're gonna make some people upset
completely by accident now the format of
the show let's get into business a lot
of fitness podcasts are you know you
have somebody on you interview them move
it on to the next episode we are going
to do interviews that'll be the second
part of each episode the first part is
going to be segments so we'll have some
time at the beginning where we kind of
chat have a little introduction we'll do
something called coach's corner where we
talk about very applied stuff you know
Greg between the two of us we've
probably coached somewhere between a
thousand and a million people oh that
seems fair right there abouts yeah
somewhere within that range so you know
we've spent years under the bar years
training people we'll talk about very
applied things with exercise technique
programming nutrition we'll also have a
segment called research review where we
talked about recent research or just
really cool research from back in the
day feats of strength as one will do
where we just talk about really strong
people doing really cool things
athletically read of the week if we read
something that was just absolutely
awesome that you should check out we'll
talk about that we'll do question and
answer segments and then finally
and a segment called to play us out and
that one we will in fact do live now
Greg if someone doesn't understand the
kind of the source of that that segment
name to play us out can you give us a
little bit of insight about that yeah
it's um it's a tribute to a man who I
think we would both consider our mentor
and in a somewhat removed type of way
our friend even and and that of course
is Bill O'Reilly yeah we're we're
venturing into the audio space
we heard that podcasts were a thing as
far as we're aware we are actually the
first fitness podcast completely
unexplored me I can't I can't keep this
straight a completely unexplored medium
within this little niche no one has ever
launched a fitness podcast before so
since we're trailblazers in this area
we're we're kind of using the show as a
tribute to someone who was a trailblazer
in another area and again of course
that's Bill O'Reilly yeah so if you need
context for what to play us out means
just Google Bill O'Reilly to play us out
and you can see a true master at work
yeah that's really why we got into this
is we knew that there's a huge part of
the potential stronger by science base
that cannot read so we wanted to tap
into that and put it all in audio so you
can kind of enjoy the content and cruise
control yeah this part to this point
we've tried to appeal to like the more
erudite Fitness audience now we're
making a hard left turn and with this
podcast we're trying to appeal to the
the mostly illiterate Fitness audience
just to make sure all of our bases are
covered right and I know for us the end
game we both want to be on Fox News some
night careto some day
but hopefully in a prime-time night slot
kind of filling billows shoes
you know so we'll see if we can walk in
those footsteps and and hey time will
tell
but for it for now that that's how we'll
end every episode and it's just a tip of
the cap to somebody who like us blazed a
trail and I think that the biggest
testament to our success if a second
fitness podcast gets started we'll know
we made our mark correct so one of the
things we want to use or we want to do
with this podcast it's going to allow us
to provide a response to the response to
some of the articles we write so you
might see us write something in mass or
stronger by science comm or in a
peer-reviewed journal like you just had
published what yesterday yeah so there's
gonna be some buzz about those things
and this gives us a chance to kind of
talk about how those things are received
so one thing we want to talk about
there's an article a few weeks ago it's
called not another boring creatine guide
answers to frequently asked questions
and lesser known benefits and you know
with creatine there's a million probably
more than a million articles out there
saying yeah creatine makes you stronger
and you can probably sprint better with
it but that article went into some of
the lesser-known aspects of creatine we
talked about a lot of things in it but
only one that mattered if if the
response to the article around the web
is any indication you're very correct
there was only one roughly 200 word
section of that article that was at all
important and relevant yeah so I mean
there was a lot of very good feedback
and I understand why it all focused in
on one aspect but people really don't
want to go ball with Greg correct they
really don't so there was a little
segment in the paper in the article that
was about linking creatine to hair loss
there's been one study that looked into
it and it feels like 90 percent of the
feedback was focusing on that we should
have made the whole article about that I
mean just thousand words on that alone
but what do you think Gregory are you
terrified at the prospect of going bald
yes that is the number one thing that
keeps me up at night along with the
homeless guy that lives in the Attic
but yeah baldness is is a terrible
scourge it's it's one of the greatest
curses of the old gods that is still
around in today's world I think we've
all had this experience you're going
about your day everything seems to be
more or less normal and then you come
across a bald person on the street and
suddenly a shiver runs down your spine
just the sheer level of spookiness is is
difficult for the human mind to process
and you just feel an instant sense of
revulsion really right but it's one of
those weird ones though where you want
to look but you don't want to look yeah
it's like a train wreck in slow motion
yeah so yeah like I mean we've seen
prominent examples of this so just think
about someone like Bruce Willis back in
the day he had a budding successful
career full head of hair very very
attractive man I think that's an
objective statement yeah and then you
know he lost all of his hair now very
disconcerting to look at his career went
to [ __ ] and when's the last we heard of
him like pulp fiction 1991 other
examples the rock Dwayne the rock
Johnson if you remember him he was the
face of the WWE in the late 90s early
2000s again full perfectly normal
natural head of hair and now look at him
man he's he's he's a grotesque shell of
what he once was so yeah I think we can
all acknowledge that really it's tough
out there for bald people so that's a
very reasonable fear to have
also the fear of bald people is also
very reasonable so it's kind of a
two-way street yeah so so yeah I can I
can certainly understand why why that
was the aspect of the article that
everyone zeroed in on yeah now what's
your take on I mean why do they keep
putting these doing the rock Johnson
types in front of us when we I mean
we're gonna be there for two hours we're
gonna be looking at the screen why do
they keep doing it I I think it's like
the the classic psychological technique
of exposure therapy yeah so you know if
someone has an intense fear of snakes
you might like you know make them look
at a snake and then make them get closer
to a snake god forbid sometimes touch a
snake and eventually it just helps them
get over their revulsion I think that
there is a cabal of bald people yeah a
hind the scenes running Hollywood that
are slowly trying to to normalize their
aberrant physical appearance yeah I
think it's kind of like a normalization
yeah yeah now it's not normal it's not
natural but they want they want us to
think that it is and it's like you know
they had that movie with the rock kind
of scale in that building that was on
fire or whatever and the whole time I'm
seeing it I'm like give me a Tom Hanks
he's got all the hair you know it give
me a Nick Jonas yeah me a whole head of
hair for this two-hour action thriller
not not the rock yeah but another thing
I always think about can you imagine how
successful Jeff Bezos would have been if
not for the implicit bias in the
business sector that's true yeah he
might have been the first self-made
trillionaire if he had hair so let's get
to business the article mentions this
paper there's one paper looking at
creatine having some kind of purported
link to hair loss one second so just to
make this incredibly clear that was a
bit I'm absolutely gonna go bald one of
these days like there's a lot of
baldness in my family it is something
I've come to expect
like the reason we use those examples is
like I think people I think a lot of
people are afraid of losing their hair
don't actually step back and look at
well if it happens like does it matter
yeah and yeah like I get you know you
have a nice head of hair you're attached
to it but like if you go bald it's fine
like yeah like you will care more than
anyone else in your life cares yeah I'm
with you I'm also gonna go bald which
means that most the people I care about
in my family are also either bald Adobe
so yeah clearly we're joking this is the
episode one thing where we actually tell
you we're being sarcastic if you miss it
in Episode two and beyond that's your
fault I think that's fair to say
yes but no so obviously someone with a
nice head of hair wants to keep that so
it's it's a very understandable reason
that that people are kind of cautious
when they they hear creatine might be
linked with hair loss it's all based on
one paper there is a single paper in
some young rugby players and it was
looking at a hormone called DHT
dihydrotestosterone and what we know
about DHT is certainly if you're
genetically predisposed to male pattern
baldness and you completely block the
DHT receptor in the scalp it will slow
the progression of hair loss so that's a
link that we have you know a great deal
of confidence and it's been shown very
conclusively now what this paper showed
again looking at young adult rugby
players they did a you know the classic
kind of crossover trial they got him at
baseline gave them a placebo for three
weeks did a little wash out phase gave
them creatine for three weeks and they
measured the DHT at baseline at day
seven and at day 21
within each condition so the same people
did both conditions in this trial now
without doing the worst thing ever in
audio format which is just to read
numbers out loud when you look at the
actual
in the paper what you see is that the
DHT levels were somewhere between about
one and one point 5 and they fluctuate
all over the place and sometimes they're
low sometimes they're high but what you
see is that they're pretty much always
within that range 1.0 to 1.5 give or
take
you would not consider a DHT value to be
particularly high until it was at like
three three point five and beyond so the
way that people look at the paper is the
creatine group saw a 50% increase in the
first seven days of the creatine
treatment they went from 0.98 to one
point five three and taken at face value
you see a 50% increase in one week in a
value like that it's it's quite jarring
at you know at first glance but
realistically speaking these DHT values
were remarkably normal throughout the
entire trial and probably most notably
what we don't know is that little
fluctuations within normal ranges of DHT
actually matter when it comes to rate of
hair loss so just because completely
blunting DHT slows down hair loss that
doesn't necessarily mean that a small
fluctuation within the normal range
actually accelerates hair loss you know
what I just realized what so so for the
audience listening at home full
disclosure this is our third time
recording this podcast because we had
audio issues the first two times and
this is something that did not occur to
me the first two times so hope hopefully
it's worth it yeah what people are
freaking out about with this paper is a
fallacy that not a fallacy but kind of a
trick that folks are very quick to
notice and call out when people are
Hawking like a weight-loss miracle cure
so like you know if there's some product
that's like on dr. oz or something and
they're trying to sell it is like the
thing that's going to help you you know
shed all of your belly fat and whatever
something they might say is like well in
a study it increased rate of fat loss by
threefold or something like that
yeah but then when you actually pull up
the
paper it's like one group lost half a
pound and the other group lost
one-and-a-half pounds and this this is
kind of a very similar thing right it's
not a particularly large increase but if
you have a reasonably low baseline or a
huge proportional increase could still
mean jack [ __ ] yeah
and yeah I think I think that's kind of
a trick that people use for marketing a
lot that folks are getting a little more
savvy too yeah and if you're not savvy
to it hopefully now you are so now you
that is a solid podcast there we go yeah
wrap it up here yeah so I think it's a
very similar thing going on here but but
less someone trying to sell you
something and more just like creating
fear yeah and and so what we see is like
the placebo condition started baseline
1.26 for some reason when they crossed
over to the creatine their baseline was
0.98 it was it was this kind of
unusually low baseline value to be
honest yeah
now I should also say that the author's
you know the I don't think they were
trying to induce any type of panic or
anything like that they weren't you know
saying but you know they they tested it
it was statistically significant they
reported it and we move on so I I don't
think the the researchers did anything
wrong or misreported they might have
been able to provide a little more
context into that yeah yeah I wasn't
saying the research record trying to
sell fear I'm saying like in the
subsequent when was that paper published
2009 I believe yeah in like the
subsequent decades since it's been
published like folks talking about this
study
[Music]
I'm not going to impugn their motives
like it could just be people click
baiting right yeah or it could just be
folks who who haven't looked into it all
that much hmm
but yeah like I think it's yeah I'm not
trying to impugn the author's motives
here and say that like they were the
merchants of fear in this context yeah
and and another thing to keep in mind
it's a bit cliche because people stay at
time and time again but a single
finding it from a single relatively
small study is never something that you
want to take you never want to blow it
out of proportion
correct however when you only have one
study on something and you want to be
evidence-based you kind of have to use
what you've got so so it's difficult
when someone says there's absolutely no
link you'd say well let's at least
acknowledge that there's this finding
out there but when it really comes down
to the the effect hair loss we've never
seen a study showing that creatine
actually accelerates that outcome it's
never been looked at but we've never
seen that and another thing is that when
you look at the DHT values I'm a little
bit skeptical that they will actually
translate to a meaningful change in the
rate of hair loss correct and we've
talked about this you kind of drew an
analogy with like steroids you know
going on like you know anabolics when it
comes to hair loss we do see that they
accelerate hair loss but it's such a
super physiological change that in the
hormone levels you know with something
like this this small fluctuation it's I
think pretty unlikely that we see a
really meaningful effect there right yes
so the the thing to keep in mind is like
just just because like thing a brings
about thing B that doesn't necessarily
mean there's a linear dose-response
curve where 50% more of thing a will
bring about 50% more of thing B so what
we know regarding DHT in hair loss is
that you like if you effectively
suppress DHT levels to essentially zero
with pharmacological interventions that
will slow hair loss what we don't know
is the degree to which variations within
the normal range and there's also at
least decent reason to believe that very
very large elevations in DHT will
probably speed up hair loss I haven't
seen any research on that specifically
but I mean that's one of the like
hallmarks side effects of steroids they
pretty consistently
calls or accelerate hair-loss so you
know I could see it being similar to
like the effects of testosterone on body
comp so I think it's really really low
bad stuff happens if it gets really
really high
people get super jacked if it's
somewhere in the normal range it's just
kind of boring and doesn't really seem
to matter all that much and it wouldn't
surprise me if the same thing generally
held true for DHT if it was super super
suppressed slows down hair loss
super super elevated accelerates it
somewhere within the normal range
probably just doesn't matter that much
well I I'm not saying that that that is
clearly the case I'm saying that that's
an explanatory model that I think is
most likely now there was some other
feedback on the article are we not going
to get into the other hair loss papers
that you found when oh yeah I forgot
about those um yeah one of the one of
the great benefits of this discussion
coming up was I got to very cautiously
tiptoe into the hair loss literature on
PubMed and it's the Wild West you know
different fields mature at different
rates and have different standards for
research and like you've mentioned to me
that a lot of the dentistry researchers
a bit some of its not not quite as as
good as you'd hope yeah it's just and
it's just it happens it's just fields
mature different different rates in
terms of how they do research an example
that the nursing field has come a
million miles in the last 30 years but
anyway you have the hair loss research I
saw one paper suggesting that gravity
played a huge role in hair loss and
particularly where hair loss occurs and
so like the entire paper was full of
like force diagrams from like you're
you're like freshman year physics class
of like where gravity's pulling on the
scalp and then relating that to where
hair loss occurs the other one which is
far more troublesome for someone like
you or me is the beard
they were positing the theory VAT and
this is that they actually had some
interesting evidence to support it but
they were saying that hair loss on the
scalp was essentially a compensatory
mechanism that when you have a thick
beard it traps heat around the face and
so your head is getting very hot in
order to dissipate some of that heat
that it loses the hair on the scalp so
that you can just ditch the heat from
the top instead of the face so I you
know there's only so many hours in a day
and only so many little detours I wish
to go on with my research reading but if
you're ever really bored and want to get
into some very interesting papers the
hair loss literature is ripe for that
Eric what so like to what degree do you
think that those are actual things to
note and be concerned about and to what
degree do you think it's like just
people throwing out hot takes that are
phrased as hypotheses so if I'm being
completely honest I don't like to boldly
throw out theories without actually
hearing them out and doing some type of
rigorous evaluation but if I make gut
level decisions and shoot from the hip
here I just don't think either of those
sound particularly plausible I would
lean more toward the idea that they're
just kind of hot hot cakes that got
thrown out there because don't we know
that at least a large portion of the
variability in hair loss is simply
explained by genetics right it seems to
be genetics and it seems to be that the
effect that DHT has on the hair follicle
itself by binding its local receptor
there is what accelerates the process
that is genetically determined I think
it's pretty straightforward so I don't
think we need have theories that involve
thermoregulation or gravity but yes I
did
completely throw it out but I one of the
basic premises of science is the concept
of parsimony yeah so when you've got a
simple and comprehensive explanation for
something just stick with it now if a
more complicated explanation explains
the the process or the effect more
effectively then then you go with it but
in this case I think the looking at
genetics as a pre determining factor and
DHT as something that actually
facilitates the outcome I think that
pretty much explains it unless I'm
missing something I mean I'll take your
word for it
that's not an area ability the
literature I know anything about I I I
actually did like your explanation of
parsimony there
I feel like oftentimes when people like
invoke Occam's razor
in an argument or in a discussion
they're not using it the way it was
intended and they're more just using it
as like a license for ignorant yeah so
so yeah like if if a more complicated
idea does explain a phenomenon better
you shouldn't just like blindly cling to
a simpler idea but yeah that's all I
have to say about that
and that's all I have to say that's this
that's concussion instance number one
but no I totally agree the two things
that I that I see are like you said I
often see misapplication of the concept
of parsimony just because it feels
better and it's easier yeah to not
consider a more complicated model
another thing I often see is a tendency
to be evidence-based until it's
inconvenient and so yeah so that
actually is a very nice segue a couple
other areas in that creatine article
that got some feedback pertained to how
caffeine mmm or I'm sorry how create
might interact with caffeine and how
creatine might cause stomach issues and
I think that those two concepts are
actually linked so a lot of people
provide a feedback on the article and
they said when I take creatine
especially if I'm loading it upsets my
stomach so if you only pay attention to
30 seconds of this podcast the value
here that I should have included in the
article on the front end if you have
stomach issues with creatine there's
some very simple ways to get around it
for most people splitting up into
smaller doses you know so if a 10-gram
dose at a single sitting so Eric one
thing I will say is the process for
amending an article on the website is
not the same as amending an article in a
scientific journal like you get is you
you you can go back and make changes
like this that's totally fine I'm going
to send a paper letter to Lindsay and in
nine months she'll respond and then
we'll discuss the possibility of
publishing a correction and a huge
apology does the does the letter itself
have to be peer-reviewed or I'd have
somebody look over it it's got to be on
letter it's at least a section editor
right yeah yeah but but I should have
included these on the front end and
maybe someday they'll find their way
into the article after that nine month
review dude just do it this weekend okay
but if it's upsetting your stomach
smaller individual doses making sure the
powder dissolves well usually using hot
a hot beverage will help out with that
and then taking it with food can be
quite helpful as well so creatine on an
empty stomach seems to really upset my
stomach and then finally this is where I
was going with this conversation there's
some literature indicating that creatine
and caffeine don't mix particularly well
and more specifically there are some
studies showing that if we give high
Urgo genic level doses of caffeine
during creatine loading we don't see the
performance benefits of creatine that we
had expected and after talking with a
bunch of people this was one area where
as I was getting at it's it's
everyone wants to be evidence-based
until they have to make a tough decision
and so there is a time there where
they're like four or five papers on this
topic and they all seem to be leaning
toward the idea but yeah like if you
give really high doses of caffeine while
you're loading creatine it just doesn't
seem to reliably enhance performance and
I talked to a bunch of really good like
really sharp people about this who
actually do sport nutrition research and
nobody wanted to hear it and it's like
well but if we're evidence-based I know
there's not a lot of evidence but we
kind of have to take what we've got and
either you know find a way to have it
and make sense with our theory or maybe
adopt a new theory so that was one of
the instances where if you tell somebody
to choose between creatine or caffeine
they will immediately stop listening and
potentially become violent because
people like both of those things but
that's I I have a question yes how many
[Music]
how many creatine papers include as an
exclusion criterion for the subjects
habitual caffeine users I I would say
very few I'm just wondering if that's a
potential mechanism for creatine
non-responders I think the non-responder
thing is much more easily explained
simply by looking at starting points for
creatine saturation mm-hm and end points
for creatine saturation in the muscle so
so like the idea that non-response rate
is a lot lower in vegetarians and vegans
than divorce right yeah so I think I
think what we see with non-responders
more often than not is that we just
didn't see a very meaningful change in
muscle creatine saturation and storage
yeah now if they were like a really
heavy heavy heavy because that's the
other thing is people used to say well
they used to in studies they would
actually mix the the creatine right into
coffee or tea which are caffeinated and
my response to that was always well
there's a difference between a 400mm
gram serving of caffeine anhydrous yeah
in a cup of coffee in the morning yeah
that's the thing a lot of people don't
realize like when when Eric said mixing
creatine with an organic dose of
caffeine like in an ERG agenda dose of
caffeine is a [ __ ] ton of caffeine it is
it's not a cup of coffee it's generally
what like 3 to 6 milligrams per kilogram
yeah and more unlike the 6 milligram per
kilogram side of things if you want to
be safe yeah you do like a 5 or 6 so if
you're if you're 200 pounds around 90
kilos it's like 540 milligrams of
caffeine which is five and a half cups
of coffee or like three and a half
monsters like that's and not like spread
throughout the day like chugging it
what like 60 to 90 minutes before a
workout right so when we talk about an
Ergo genic dose of caffeine like we're
talking about a [ __ ] ton of caffeine
yeah but but yeah so you bring up this
concept of people and they don't really
want to deal with it because it's a lot
simpler to say caffeine works creatine
works use both we're good but more and
more I'm thinking that and after talking
to people who know a lot more than me
about it
it really seems like the combination of
the two a high high high dose of
caffeine with a loading dose of creatine
it seems like it just upsets people's
stomachs yeah
and so Roger Harris published an
abstract I wish he would have written
the the paper up for it but they never
bothered but I think they demonstrated
that really well that when they gave the
combination together people really their
stomachs didn't like it and then after
they were kind of removed from
supplementation for a little bit they
actually their performance actually kind
of trended back closer to what we would
expect yeah so that's all to say if
you're having stomach issues aside from
making sure it dissolves and tweaking
the dosing a little bit taking it with
food maybe avoidance of very high
caffeine doses might help as well you
know so that this is this is a bit of a
detour but one of the things that urged
me a little bit about supplement
research and where we're talking about
the now kind of touches on this is that
like pretty much all of the research
just looks at like a single compound in
isolation
or like you know maybe how a certain
compound interacts with antioxidants or
something in the case of like nitrate
supplements yeah
but for the most part like there aren't
that many studies on multi ingredient
type supplements and the ones that are
out there are typically sponsored by the
people that manufacture their
supplements so there's like some
conflict of interest issues there and we
we can't know for sure what interaction
multiple supplements have together until
that's actually tested so like the
simplest thing would just be if they're
additive so you know maybe creatine
gives you 510 percent caffeine gives you
another two three percent just add those
two numbers together and that is the
percent improvement you might expect to
see so that that's like the simplest
model or in the case of caffeine and
creatine it may be like an inhibitory
thing where the sum is less than the
whole or the whole is less than the sum
of its parts or it could be where like
the whole is greater than the sum of its
parts where like you know two things are
better together than they would be in
isolation I know that sticking the
creatine there's some evidence that you
get a little bit better creatine
absorption if you combine it with
bicarbonate so who knows like in that
case it may be something where you know
creatine and bicarbonate both might do a
little something by themselves and when
you put them together they're even
better than the sum of the two effects
and like I mean I get that there's not
like thousands of supplement trials
constantly ongoing but most people do
take a mix of supplements it's not like
you know I only take creatine and that
is the only thing I ever take most
people are you know especially if you
take like a pre-workout that's like a
blend of like seven or eight different
things typically and like even if all of
those things do do a little bit some a
little bit of something by themselves
you can't know that
you can just add those effects together
and assume that that's what the
combination will give you right yeah and
it's a good point and I know
jason khalipa down at Coastal Carolina
he's a sport nutrition professor he
talks about that a lot the idea that we
actually do need to start testing these
combinations that everybody's using but
they're assuming that all the
independent effects are kind of adding
in you know completely complimentary
fashion well I mean it's the same thing
with training studies as well and and I
feel like people do understand this when
it comes to training studies but
understand it less when it comes to
supplement research so you know there's
research that higher volumes are good
and there's research that higher
intensities are good if you just put
this up yeah if you just put those two
findings together completely naively
well sure let's just do you know 30
triples per workout with 90 percent of
your max and like that must be the best
way to get swole yeah like no in six
days a week yeah of course yeah as
frequency might be good as well so yeah
let's just put all of those things
together and like you know people hear
that it was like of course that's not
how it works but that seems to be the
implicit assumption for how it works
with supplements which you know may be
the case may not be the case tell the
studies are done we can't know for sure
yeah so another thing that comes up a
lot you know we're speaking about
caffeine a little bit is I feel like
this third take for the podcast is
actually turning out like a fair bit
more informative than the other ones I
think so I think the new policy moving
forward should be everything we do we do
it thrice oh god okay so whenever you
talk caffeine genetics comes up a lot
because there's there's been some new
research really over the last five or
ten years showing that you know
different genetic predisposition to
caffeine metabolism seems to have a
potentially meaningful effect on how
your body reacts to caffeine potentially
when it comes to long-term health
outcomes potentially when it comes to
sport performance certainly when it
comes to how quickly it's metabolized
yeah so there's the the cyp one A two
I think that's off memory so somebody
can fact check me but I'm sure that's
right it's definitely a cytochrome p450
isozyme of some type but just just
flexing on them their tricks one a to in
some combination yeah but it's it's let
a lot of people to get into this I mean
now you can get your genetics tested
quite easily with just a
direct-to-consumer kind of thing you buy
a kit you send it in and they let you
know if you're a fast or slow caffeine
metabolizer now you recently wrote an
article for the site that talked a
little bit about it almost like a
cautionary tale of how knowing your
genetics in some cases you might know a
little too much for your own good
do you mind giving a little summary of
that that article but both too much and
too little
yeah so we we recently republish an
article on the site that originally
appeared in Mass the title of the
article which I should have pulled up
and don't I have it pulled up well what
was the title when I said you're just
hanging me out to dry when I said we
weren't gonna try I meant Greg wasn't
gonna try Jesus Christ well you're the
one with the outline over there I don't
know what we're about to get into okay
it's called genetics based expectations
affect your physiology well I had it
pulled up by this time and you used the
correct form of effect which is that
puts you in the top 0.001 percent of the
population but it's my editor in the top
0.01% of the population yes so so what
they did in this study is they it was
actually two different studies both with
pretty large cohorts with like over a
hundred people per study and both of the
studies were written up as one paper and
so what they did is in each one they
would have people perform a battery of
tests or assessments and they would also
give a blood sample they'd send the
blood sample off to the lab and look at
what allele variant of a particular gene
those people had
and then at random they would tell them
if they had the like quote-unquote good
version or bad version the the term in
the terminology they used from the study
was high risk or low risk but they they
told so they they knew what allele
variants that people actually had but
they told them they had either the good
one or the bad one at random and then
they would repeat the same battery of
tests so in one study they were looking
at the kreb one gene CREB one which has
implications for aerobic exercise and
thermoregulation and in the other study
they were looking at the FTO gene which
has implications with hunger satiety and
obesity and so again just to recap they
put them through some tests sequenced
their their genome and then you know
told some people the correct so
basically like a quarter of the people
had like the good version of the gene
we're told they had the good version
about a quarter of the people had the
bad version we're told they had the good
version about a quarter of the people
had the bad version we're told they had
the bad version and about a quarter of
the people had the good version but
we're told they had the bad version and
then repeated those same those same
battery of tests and so for the study
looking at the kreb one gene they looked
at things like maximum co2 2:02 exchange
rate pretty similar to respiratory
exchange ratio they looked at
perceptions of heat they looked at time
to task failure during an aerobic test
and just things like that and for the
FTO study the one implicated in hunger
satiety and obesity they looked at a
hormone called geo p1 which is
implicated in satiety they looked at
self-reported fullness and they also
looked at another hormone called
isolated ghrelin and so essentially what
they found is that for most of the
outcomes they looked at regardless of
whether someone actually had the good
a bad version of those jeans if you told
someone hey you have the good version of
this gene they had the the they had a a
positive both perceptual and
physiological response so for example
with the kreb one study regardless of
whether people have the the good or bad
version of the kreb one gene they would
report feeling more overheated sooner
during the exercise session if you told
them they had the bad version of that
gene or the and so you could hear that
and say well that's not all that
impressive that's a classic nocebo
effect you're telling someone
something's wrong and they have negative
perceptions but it actually affected
physiology as well so it affected
ventilation so like breathing kinetics
and it affected the co2 2:02 exchange
rate as well for the FTO study the
people who were told they had the good
version of the gene reported greater
fullness after consuming a standardized
meal which again you could hear that and
say wow that that's not too impressive
like that's just a perceptual response
could be a placebo effect but they also
had a greater elevation in glp-1 which
is a hormone associated with satiety so
again not just a perceptual response but
also a physiological response and then
they also did an analysis comparing
[Music]
comparing basically whether genotypes
matter like the actual genotype mattered
more or the perceived genotype mattered
more and for co2 202 exchange rate for
perceived feelings of overheating for
GOP one and for perceived fullness the
perceived genotype actually mattered
more than the actual genotype people had
so like perceptions they're mattering
more than the actual genetics so I think
I think people could hear that and
probably like draw too strong of
conclusions like the impression I get is
that Greg no
goals before God in country is saying
that your genes don't matter mindset is
everything mind over matter and don't be
weak yes so so that's the hot take
version okay which i think is probably
too strong of a takeaway but yeah i do
think that something we can see from
this study is that is that people may
like somewhat overreact both like
perceptually and physiologically to
negative information about their genes
and so like I've never been very high on
direct consumer genetic testing like
23andme
and similar services and and one of the
reasons why is one of the genes that
23andme looks at is your a CT and 3y or
a CT and three gene a see it codes for a
protein that essentially affects
shortening velocity of fast twitch
fibers and one pretty consistent
research finding is that elite strength
and power athletes are more likely to
have one version of that gene than
another version of that gene and so I'm
pretty sure that's the only like
strength power related gene that 23andme
looks at it might look at it might look
at one or two others but that's like
that's the main one that people bring up
to me all the time and so people will
message me and say like hey I did
23andme and it said that I have the bad
version of the a CT and three gene like
am I screwed and like no they're not so
if you if you look at like even elite
sprinters for whom maximum shortening
velocity is going to matter way more for
them than it would for like power
lifters something like half of the
competitors at like elite like national
and world class levels have at least one
of the bad copies of the AC TN 3 gene
and something like 14 percent have two
of the bad alleles so it may be one of
those things that you know if you don't
have the correct genotype there it could
stop you from becoming Usain Bolt
but clearly a non-negligible number of
people are capable of being like
national and world-class sprinters with
the wrong genotype there and then also
like it's just not telling you that much
so in 2011 there was a review paper
published basically going over all of
the different independent genes that had
been found to that point that affected
strength power phenotypes and as of 2011
there were 22 genes that were known and
so like if 23andme is only testing for a
CT and three like of the known strength
power genotype that people knew about in
2011 so I'm sure there's more genes that
people have identified now knowing about
that one gene locus only tells you about
four-and-a-half percent of that strength
power genotype it's like it's not
telling you jack [ __ ] right um but like
yeah I've seen so many people get that
one little bit of information from
23andme and start like catastrophizing
it saying like well my genes suck I'm
never gonna get big and strong and like
one that's not even what a CT and three
does it's it's about shortening velocity
it's not about hypertrophic potential or
like maximum contractile force potential
it's just shortening velocity so yeah
like maybe if you want to be like a
sprinter or a shotput thrower put some
stock in it you want to be a power
lifter a bodybuilder probably doesn't
matter all that much and even if it did
you know that's telling you about one
out of 22 genes that may make a
difference so yeah like I think that I
think that this study speaks to the more
general idea of like expectancy effects
yeah and if you have positive expectancy
like if you go into something expecting
a good outcome you are more likely to
have a good outcome regardless of your
physiology and if you go into something
expecting a bad outcome you're more
likely to have a worse outcome it's like
if you just have like a [ __ ] genetic
drum and you expect good things you're
probably still not gonna get great
results but you're gonna get better
results than you would have otherwise if
you went into it like with a fatalistic
out-out outlook and and the same thing
like if you have good genes for lifting
and you go in thinking that your average
or you suck like you're so probably
gonna get decent outcomes just because
like that's what your genes are
influencing you towards but you're
probably not going to accomplish as much
as you otherwise would have so yeah I
don't think I don't think the the level
of information you can get from like
direct consumer genetic testing inspires
much confidence like it it tells you
about such a small portion of various
polygenetic traits that it's not worth
much in the first place and if it gives
you if it gives you an undesirable
result about a gene that influences some
aspect of physiology you care about like
that could know see about you and in the
case of like the strength power
phenotype your other 21 genes may be
fantastic and they're just testing for a
CT and 3 and you come away with the
complete wrong conclusion so yeah I
think I think one of these days gene
testing may be worth something and I
think in like clinical and lab
applications it's worth something but I
think for the most part like direct
consumer genetic taste testing is a
waste of time and money and likely to do
more harm than good yeah and I mean like
you said first of all you're with many
of these things you're not getting the
complete picture by looking at a single
gene and also I always advocate against
asking questions that you don't actually
intend to act upon right yes so we've
talked about this when you were in full
like thesis mode you were running a
study and two companies and you were
consuming enough caffeine every day to
probably kill a rhinoceros if not an
elephant correct and if at that time I
said hey Greg bad news man your saliva
sample came back
you're a pretty slow caffeine
metabolizer you might want to lay off
what were you realistically gonna do
with that information absolutely nothing
nothing at all so if you love
weightlifting or powerlifting or just
lifting in general someone comes back
and says hey this one particular gene
could have been better yeah come on
don't don't throw that away and convince
yourself that you're screwed over that
you know yeah now the one thing I love
about that paper is obviously the
subjective stuff you would expect yeah
but the fact that the physiology changed
I find absolutely fascinating from just
the just the expectation and one of the
things you talk about in the article is
that classic study it's not old but it's
classic I forget what you're told are
you talking the the aerial study I'm
talking the the steroid one yeah that's
old that's what was 1974 oh then it's
doubly classic yeah hold and incredible
but wasn't it like they convinced they
told the the subjects they were on
steroids and they put like a hundred
pounds on their total or something like
that yeah so the entire duration of the
study was 11 weeks they recruited people
and told them we're gonna train you
really hard for seven weeks we're gonna
test squat bench press military press
and seated military press because they
have the correct priorities and they
know that pressing is the only thing
that matters so we're gonna train you
really hard we're gonna test you on
those four lifts pre and post and the
ones of you that make the best progress
we're gonna give you free legal steroids
so like they're in deal so like on the
front and they're incentivizing people
to train hard and make as much progress
as possible because they're dangling
that carrot in front of them but then at
the end of the first seven weeks they
just like randomly selected a sample of
their original sample instead of taking
the people who were like pre-selected
yet to make the best progress
and then they gave them saccharine
tablets and told them that I think I
think they told them that it was d ball
have them trained for another four weeks
and tested them again and so from for
the first seven weeks of the study they
put a combined total of I believe twenty
no they put a combined total of ten
kilos so 22 pounds on those four lifts
put together which like that's like five
pounds of lift which you know if we're
talking about like elite level athletes
like yeah whatever it is what it is but
these guys they were like intermediate
lifters at best I want to say they're
the squad max at the start of the study
was like 350 360 so like you know they
had some prior training experience but
these weren't like elite power lifters
so yeah like they put about 10 kilos on
those four lifts put together which
isn't anything to write home about then
in the ones that were given the like
placebo steroids for just four weeks
they put forty five kilos which is like
right at a hundred pounds on those four
lifts in just four weeks so so we're
talking we're going from ten kilos in
seven weeks to forty five kilos in four
weeks which is like almost an Eightfold
increase in rate of progress and like
the only change was people were told
that they were being given steroids even
though they weren't and I just think
that's wild and so one thing I will say
is the the main study I was talking
about the the turn walls study looking
at the kreb gene and the FTO gene like
we said earlier in the podcast it's
improper to put too much faith in just
like one single research finding at
least the stuff they found with like the
the diet portion of the study with the
FTO gene was basically a replication of
a prior study as well where what they
did in that study was instead of
manipulating people's expectations about
their genetic profile they manipulated
people's expectations about what they
were actually putting into their body so
in that study they used milkshakes and
they gave
they gave three different groups of
people milkshakes or maybe the same
group three different times I can't
remember which but they keep in
milkshakes in all of the milkshakes for
380 calories and what they did is they
manipulated the labeling of the
milkshake so so no it was only two
different milkshakes that they gave them
so one of the labels basically portrayed
it as like this very indulgent dessert
type milkshake like a lot of fat a lot
of sugar the label said that it was 620
calories and you know like the visuals
of it were like that of an indulgent
dessert and the other milkshake again
exact same 380 calories milkshake it was
labeled to say that it was only a
hundred and forty calories and it was
presented as like a light healthy
alternative to you know bad unhealthy
fatty milkshakes but the exact same
milkshake just just labeled and packaged
2 different ways and in that one they
also looked at fullness and satiety and
they looked at ghrelin which again is is
associated with hunger and when people
drank what they thought was the 620
calorie milkshake fullness was greater
satiety was greater
again those are perceptual responses
very prone to placebo effects not that
exciting but there were also big
differences in ghrelin in that study as
well so you know that's like an actual
physiological thing like that's that's a
hormone being affected that like does
calls hunger just simply by manipulating
people's expectations about what they
put into their body which is very very
similar to the findings of like the FTO
portion of that other study we were
talking about yeah so these it appears
to be a you know at least in a couple
instances a fairly reliable finding that
some of these expectations can kind of
have some influence on a variety of
these physiological responses yeah not
even the subjective ones
now the study finding that 100-pound
gain and strength in four weeks would it
be controversial to suggest that those
are near hmb level gains that were
okay I I think I think that is a fair
thing to say now for our first ever
podcast interview we got Peter Fitch and
on and so we talked to him about HM be
if you don't know who Peter is he's a
pro natural bodybuilder he coaches a
bunch of bodybuilders did a PhD in
nutrition where he studied hmb he did
some some research on blood flow
restricted training we got into that and
he shamelessly tried to shill his new
bodybuilding book on our podcast in the
interview and we we shut that down
immediately I I could not sit there and
take the disrespect
it was insane we're trying to ask him
questions about science and stuff and
all he wants to do is sell things it was
like a used-car lot yeah and it's also
like dude like we built this platform
100 million listeners at night 100
million listeners we put in the work
we're not going to allow some hack to
come on and a great hack I love Peter
he's a very good hack yeah but to abuse
this platform that we've put our blood
sweat and tears into building to to
shill for some ebook which I'm sure is a
perfectly fine eBook
it's actually a real book through like
human kinetics oh never mind
it's like made out of like leather and
show shows Cambridge the shame on you
yeah so so stay tuned for that interview
and by the way when you hear our
interviews if we make like references to
like how poorly current President
Obama's doing it's cuz they've been in
the can for weeks so if we make a
completely dated reference it's because
most of these recorded were recording
like the late 1990s basically correct
they're quite old but we're gonna get
rolling we're gonna find we're gonna get
rolling we're gonna find a rhythm we're
gonna get these episodes out regularly
every two weeks
sure we'll aim for every two weeks and
you know get that hundred million
listenership up to I don't know tens of
thousands
tens of thousands of hundred millions
well I think it's a figure of speech so
in in the two towers when Saruman looks
over his army of works
he definitely has more than tens of
thousands so I think that just signifies
an indiscriminately large number okay
fair enough yeah so yeah we will get
consistent with that stay tuned for the
interview with tens of thousands is like
the highbrow version of over 9000 okay
now before we get to that interview Greg
somebody's gotta play us out and to play
us out I have part one of a one part
installment the first and final
installment of a segment I'm calling
Eric's Seder stories okay so I was
invited to my first ever Seder over the
past week or so and it's incredibly kind
to invite so I'm not Jewish to invite
someone into your home to participate in
something like that
it's such a kind thing to do I was so
honored that they would let me
experience that with them and so when
you go into something like that you want
to be extremely polite you know you want
to have an appropriate amount of
reverence for the event and so I'm like
all right be on your best behavior
like show respect be overly kind and
overly non-controversial in all
conversations just out of respect now
we're sitting around the table and
someone you know we're all just being
polite you know I don't know many of the
people there and someone asked me what I
do for a living and Greg you know this I
completely gave up on life I was you
know perfectly groomed to be a professor
and now I'm the assistant to a blogger
and when people say assistant blogger I
say no assistant to a blogger but
someday I might be a blogger myself it's
like a dwight shrute michael scott
relations exactly i am the assistant to
a blogger but I always said yeah but I
did do it like I'm I'm okay like I did
do it like a PhD or whatever and they
said a PhD and what and I said
every my PhD is in human movement
science but when I tell people that they
think I'm like an anthropologist they
think it's like movement of human
civilizations across the globe
so I every time someone asked me what I
studied I give a different term exercise
science sports science kinesiology
something like that so this time I said
kinesiology big mistake big mistake so
again we're both trying to be
excessively polite because we don't know
each other this is a religious event I'm
just I'm literally just so someone
thought you got a doctorate in PE no
nurse so I'm just like incredibly
thankful they would even invite me into
their home so I'm trying to be very
polite
now I said kinesiology do you know his
response was what he kind of got like a
smile like and he says a lot of skeptics
out there okay and I said are there and
so I'm trying to be more like I I did
not know that there were exercise
science skeptics as a whole like are
there people out there who are saying
like I don't think heart rate goes up
when you run you know well I our
president still holds the belief that
you have like a predefined amount of
energy that you have to like pace
throughout your life so it doesn't run
out yes that number of heartbeats yes so
I said there there is some level of
exercise science skepticism that is
alive and well at the at the top of our
government that was the first thing that
came to my mind yeah and so I was gonna
let him take it there because I'm like
look it up the story goes like anything
political yeah yeah yeah now after some
digging I'm reading from a website here
the headline is well let me just start
how it says kinesiology is a science
involving the study of human movement
whether voluntary or involuntary yeah
good start yeah I'm on board with that
kinesiology is widely applied in sports
science and orthopedics and here's where
it take it takes a turn sure but did you
know that you can also apply it in
conjunction with your crystals what
you can also apply it in conjunction
with your crystals interesting so Eric's
later Harry you have me hooked basically
there's this whole like sub field out
there that I had no idea about that is
like trying to weave kinesiology
together with using like minerals and
crystals and rocks and stuff to like
it's like did you notice that when you
held the crystal in your hand that it
made your that hand a lot stronger sure
makes sense so basically I was sitting
at the table and the person was trying
to be polite and just say well that's
nice I don't I there's some merit to it
I can't believe there's all these
terrible skeptics out there just to
humor me and they thought I did my PhD
in how minerals when we hold them make
us substantially stronger obviously some
type of light I just is that is that a
is that a common thing floating around
out there I had never heard of it until
this past weekend and it made me feel
I already feel horrible about my life
decisions I didn't think I could feel
worse I mean so so I'm gonna say
something and I'm gonna try not to be
discriminatory here cuz should you not
say it yeah I'm going to we gave that
disclaimer no because I feel like I can
say this because I at one point in my
life was one of these people these are
these are Asheville people right uh
there are a lot of crystal stores in
Nashville I can tell you that yeah I
mean so that could be something where if
you said kinesiology to someone from
Asheville that means a completely
different thing than if you say it to
someone who lives virtually anywhere
else in the country yeah I just I had no
idea that this like crystal subculture
had commandeered kinesiology and claimed
it for their own
so I spent that entire night not
realizing that everyone at the table
thought I've done my PhD in kind of the
spiritual healing powers of crystals and
how they affect perform like when I
finally found this website it was sent
to me the
as I brought this up did you did you
have an opportunity to correct the
record at any point no we just had
complete I just continued the
conversation the most confused I had
ever been in my entire life and I really
want to reiterate they were purely doing
it because they were it was a very very
nice person who was simply humoring you
you should have just asked like bro like
what do you think I do it we eventually
got there but again trying to be as you
know like very polite non
confrontational just like trying not to
rock the boat because I don't I don't
know what what everyone is on board with
you know but it was just a completely
like two parallel conversations I was
talking about like you know weight
training and I didn't know you're
talking about minerals I got very
confused crystals and minerals and yeah
so apparently the the there's this whole
world out there and again they were just
trying to humor me and trying to comfort
me and make me not feel so bad about the
fact that I dedicated ten years of my
life to that it was incredible it was so
sweet of them to humor me and it was not
until days after that I realized wow I
didn't know what that conversation was
about until now I mean has has your
girlfriend at least like tried to take
the opportunity to set the record
straight with her faith
where was she in all of this I think
like what was she at the table with you
I think equally confused okay yeah she
dug up the the link to the article
several days later and I see I think I
understand why why this conversation was
so disjointed and confusing for I see
yeah I I was wondering if it was
something where like she knows her
family she knew that they were thinking
that you didn't know that and she just
hung you out to dry just to watch me
squirm yeah I don't think she's I don't
think she's cruel enough to let that
happen I mean if she is I'd rather not
know I mean the fact that she knew
enough about it to find that link like
if you're just having that conversation
and you don't know that it means
crystals what search terms are you going
to punch in
Krystal's come up i don't know i don't
know how she stumbled upon i was a trail
of brick I'm actually yeah yeah as we
speak I'm getting very suspicious and a
little a lot bit upset because obviously
she knew how to find that yeah so yeah
so the moral of the story is if you're a
dressed women if you're a young student
out there studying kinesiology and you
go home for like Thanksgiving that was a
joke by the way
what do you say I just said you can't
trust women oh that's horrible I was I
was just trying to get the hottest take
I thought we were gonna make it to the
second episode we're not that's that's a
joke I respect women but really if I
didn't my wife would kick my ass she's
scary
but sweet yeah no your wife is
objectively better than you in every way
and you and I both know that I'm not
gonna contest that for a for a second
yeah so the moral of the story a lot of
the people listening to our podcast
maybe studied a kinesiology related
field or they're thinking about it when
you go home for Thanksgiving you go home
for a seder you go home for whatever be
very specific about your terminology
just call it exercise science just call
it exercise science it's a lot easier it
doesn't sound as fancy but it gets the
job done yeah now to finish out this
episode we've got an awesome interview
we recorded with Peter fishin and we
hope you enjoy it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today we are joined by Peter fiction so
first of all Peter welcome and thank you
for joining us yeah thanks for having me
now Peter I understand that you have a
PhD and your natural pro bodybuilder is
this correct yeah that that is correct
Gregg will you agree that anyone with
those two credentials is kind of
automatically a legend and a hero i I
don't think that's an unfair assessment
okay so that's on record perfect so I
got what I wanted out of this important
but let's go for it anyway so Peter for
people who don't know who you are you
know you did your PhD at University of
Illinois you're an nga pro bodybuilder
what else do people need to know about
who you are and what you do yeah so yeah
so I I would say educationally I got a
my PhD at the University of Illinois I
got my bachelor's a masters so my PhD is
in nutrition my bachelor's and master's
are actually more basic biology so I
have a bachelor's in biochem and a
master's in Physiology um I got CSCS I'm
a certified strength conditioning
specialist my big competing since 2004
lifting since 2002 so I'm not all that
old but I always kind of feel like the
old guys I'm like yeah my first shift
like I told someone yesterday at the gym
yeah my first show was 15 years ago next
month you know like yeah how old were
you when you started I was eight I
started lifting a 16 did my first show
at 18 but I mean I was like 145 onstage
like I I mean I gained I went from 140
125 to 170 in the first year and a half
of lifting and still didn't look like I
lifted but then dieted for a show yeah
I'm careful with the body weight talk I
I'm a bantamweight so just relax yeah I
well I mean I might yeah when I went my
pro card I was in the 160s and when I
did my first pro shows I was actually
like 158 159 carved up so I was even
leaner so yeah I'm not a very big guy
but yeah I it took a long time for me to
look like I actually lifted yeah yeah
and so other than that I've published I
think 18 peer-reviewed publications
although there's
another one that's been accepted so I
think it'll be 19 soon some of that's
related to bodybuilding some of its
other nutrition stuff a lot of what I
did in grad school was muscle loss and
dialysis patients and research my
dissertation was actually hmb
supplementation and dialysis patients i
think either than that I got a book that
is coming out here in the next couple
weeks it's been selling really well
which is really cool because it's not
even out yet so pretty pumped to finally
get that out
appear this is a podcast not a
commercial ok let's try to keep on
unfocused this isn't just some sales
mccann Deveny for you Peter we're trying
to get information out to the people
every I think every podcast I've done
quite a few podcasts recorded quite a
bit of stuff lately and everyone is it's
like promote your book promote your book
drove to Illinois or Indiana to go meet
up with cliff and just record a bunch of
stuff for the fact where the book yeah
we don't we don't we don't do that
around here that's that's not that's not
the game we play not at all if anyone
spends a dime on something that we don't
own we are automatically against that so
we're gonna go back and edit out that
advertisement that you just put in but
okay so I'm glad that you brought up
research because I did have a couple
questions for you so you did your
dissertation on HMV and I don't want to
put you on the spot but I looked back at
some of your HMV papers mm-hmm
none of them showed seven eight ten
kilogram increases in lean mass and so I
guess the first question is really a
two-part question part one how did you
guys blow this this badge and part two
are you willing to apologize publicly
yeah yeah I mean you know actually so I
know you're talking about the the like
the huge gains and the and some of like
the Wilson research they Wilson Wilson
among others yes among others but they
actually replicated that that study and
didn't find anything recently
if I if I'm recall correctly but I I was
mainly looking at clinical populations
because even so when I was kind of when
I was in grad school that was before
some of the data that seemed almost too
good to be true and athletes came out
and so I was looking more elderly
clinical populations because we have the
population of dialysis patients we were
running a multi-site NIH clinical trial
it would be pretty easy to you know what
I mean
for me to recruit dialysis patients they
have muscle-wasting you know no no
studies had been done and HMV in
dialysis patients there were results
that I would say are borderline too good
to be true in AIDS patients and cancer
cachexia and you know some of the
elderly some you know some of these
other populations that tend to have
muscle loss and so you know I thought
I'll you know so we designed a study and
you know even in our like the review we
wrote on hmb and elderly and clinical
populations we were very you know very
like I don't know kind of skeptic you
know what I mean you kind of very tried
to kind of dance around the fact that
yeah you know this is almost too good to
be true that you're seeing like 2
kilogram increases in lean mass and like
12 weeks and someone who's wasting and
things like that and you know so we just
did the study and and you know the
results are what the results are and we
it was six months so as it was one of
the longest term HIV supplementation
studies today it's six months
double-blind placebo-controlled we check
compliance with blood a couple of times
throughout the intervention and and yeah
we we found pretty much no difference in
anything measured and and just so the
listeners are aware I'm being a smartass
Peters group did some excellent work on
hmb and if you want to understand what
we're referring to Greg wrote an article
on stronger by science about some of the
too-good-to-be-true
type HMV studies now I did want to ask a
serious question about HMV based on the
work you've done the reviews you've
written
do you see an application for HMB in any
kind of physique or strength athlete and
basically who who could it be useful for
if anyone yeah I mean
I don't know at this point I don't
really recommend it to any strength or
physique athlete I could maybe see some
rationale like if someone had a really
low protein intake and we're at risk of
muscle loss like maybe you know they
maybe that would be a situation where
there might be some benefit like that
would that would be the place I would
look if I was looking to see if there
was a benefit probably but what about
what about just for like new lifters
because there's fairly consistent
evidence there yeah there there's some
muscle damage stuff in new lifters that
it might help prevent muscle damage and
reduce soreness and and accelerate
recovery so maybe you know in them but
it you know the effect how much of a
difference is it gonna make I don't know
and it's it's relatively expensive I
don't know what the cost is now because
I haven't looked to buy it recently but
I know at the time we were doing the
study it was like a dollar a day to get
a three gram dosage which was the dosage
used in basically all the research well
see Peter that's that's the mistake you
made if you if you're willing to accept
some reasonable level of lead
contamination you can buy it you can buy
a thousand kilos for like 50 bucks on
Alibaba in your set yeah yeah yeah you
know but I I just I don't know you know
a lot of times with supplements you have
the ones that you know Eric would
probably agree with this you have the
ones that clearly seem to do something
the ones that clearly seem to not and
then you kind of have the ones well
maybe in this situation maybe this row
we need some more data that kind of gray
area and with a lot of the great ones
it's like okay well if there's no risk
and the only risk is losing money then
it's how much money do you want to spend
on something that may or may not do
something yeah I kind of ran into that
first I want to mention I love the fact
that you did your dissertation on hmb
and your first response was I don't know
I think I think that means you're really
good at science honestly like I'm not
being as smart as I really love that we
kind of ran into the same thing with my
dissertation where like you know with
some of the beetroot studies you see
it's like
if you want to actually get the
effective dose from a quality tested
product you're looking at five to six
grams a day or five to six dollars a day
oh man which is a lot and to address
Greg's point on the contaminated HMV
Peter would you agree that for a
hemodialysis patient high lead
contamination would be contraindicated
yeah yeah we actually had to test to
make sure even taking hmb we had to get
approval to just do like acute pilot
studies unlike time course of of how
quickly is it cleared in them and is it
cleared because some of it is cleared by
the kidney I don't remember the exact
percentage but like a quarter or a third
or something like that of HMV is is
cleared by the kidney and so it was
still okay and everything was fine but
that was something we had to test ahead
of time also yeah now kind of shifting
gears a little bit I saw you also did I
think one study on blood flow restricted
training is that correct yeah yeah we we
have another one I don't know I've my
co-author hasn't written it apparently
or something yet but we have to it's
just only ones been published okay so
kind of a similar question for bfr it's
been one of those things that I've
always been kind of loosely interested
in it is is blood flow restrictor
training something that you often tell
your own clients to do or that you you
apply yourself in your training no not
really at this point my so maybe I'm way
off base on this because I feel like I'm
the only like science-based bodybuilder
that isn't on the HMV train sorry on the
blood flow restriction train but you
know my thought at this point is you
know a lot of the studies out there on
blood flow restriction training they
look at high load blood flow restriction
training so like you know train or sorry
high load training so 7080 percent
whatever normal load training and they
compared that to low load training with
blood flow restriction and they see the
same amount of gains and they say look
there's no difference that's how a lot
of them have been done so when we set up
our study we did we volume matched so we
did basically low load training and low
low training
you know basically with or without a
cuff and so that we could basically
match and the only difference with a
cuff grant do we use beginners which is
a limitation but we didn't see any
difference and my I guess my thought is
if you combine that with some of Brad
Schoenfeld Stu work that shows that you
can see similar gains doing low load you
know I think he was doing 25 to 35 rep
range stuff taken to failure and you see
similar games there to high load
training I guess I questioned what the
need for a cuff is you know what I mean
so I'm I'm not aware of the exact
mechanism but there have been I think
two or three papers now comparing high
load training alone versus high load
training plus low load with blood flow
restriction plus high load versus low
load without blood flow restriction yeah
and it seems like the supplemental blood
flow restriction work may not really do
that much for hypertrophy but it seems
to increase strength games versus high
load alone or high load Plus low load
without blood flow restriction so that's
that wouldn't be incredibly relevant to
like physique athletes but now for a
strength athlete if they're looking to
increase their gains without adding a
bunch of additional heavy loading I'm
not sold that it's going to have a huge
effect but that's the thing that
interests me the most about it
personally yeah yeah I just I don't know
I I just like i said when brad some of
Brad's work came out and I just like I
fit that into what I kind of had thought
and I was like man that that you know
what I mean that kind of really fits
with what I was thinking that you know
if you can just grow from doing low load
training hard close to failure
you know why add it then again maybe
some of those strength adaptations
that's interesting to me though that it
would be it would enhance strength and
not hypertrophy you know what I mean
like the low load with blood flow
restriction yeah they throw out like a
purported mechanism for that yeah yeah
but the the mechanism they tend to throw
out doesn't really make much sense to me
that's kind of why I was asking the the
mechanism they tend to throw out is
if you look at EMG in Lolo training
versus Lolo training with blood flow
restriction you see greater EMG
amplitudes with blood flow restriction
than without and so they're saying like
oh it may be increased neuromuscular
actor activation that's improving
strength gains but it's still less like
still lower EMG amplitudes than you'd
see with high-low training so I don't
know that that makes all that much sense
I think it's more just that it not not
like the magnitude of the of the EMG but
more just it affects motor patterns in
some way and so I see it is more of kind
of like a novelty type thing and there
is research showing that doing similar
but slightly different things can
improve motor learning so I think that
maybe what it is so it's it's doing the
same exercise while also undergoing an
intervention that affects perception
somewhat and so I think it may be
improving motor learning that way but I
haven't seen that put forth in a paper
as a purported mechanism so I could be
completely off-base but that's just the
potential explanation that makes the
most sense to me yeah so so Peter even
with with injure death I mean with
injured athletes you don't send them off
and say hey try some blood flow
restriction you just kind of tell him to
chill until we're ready to go I mean I
would I would just do lower loads you
know and I mean just it would be the
same concept I mean just I don't know
why you know what I mean why do you need
cuff like just you can do sets of like
30 with low loads you know if that's
pain-free and while you're recovering
and make progress as long as you're you
know training close enough to failure
one thing though we did see in the lab
you know with with blood flow
restriction is you know they see this in
other studies too if you put a cuff on
someone and you take the same load and
you have them go to failure you can do
significantly fewer wraps with the cuff
so it decreases you know the time to
failure but I don't know if you're not
seeing the difference in like you know
hard outcome
in a study like hypertrophy I don't know
if that necessarily matters yeah the
other thing is you're like oh well maybe
I won't have to push those those you
know tough final reps of that set still
be tough final yeah this come sooner say
yeah it's like you just skip all the all
the introductory stuff and get right
into the horrible pain yeah because I
did a little bfr back in the day when I
had a knee injury and it's certainly not
a shortcut to size
that's not sure it hurts there there's
there's also something I think that
doesn't get talked about enough is I
think there's also non-negligible risk
with blood flow restriction training so
not necessarily risk in terms of like
actual bad things are gonna happen but
it seems that blood flow blood flow
restriction training can be neutral too
good if you're cutting off like venous
blood flow but not arterial but unless
you have a way to check that I think a
lot of people get their bands way too
tight and end up cutting off our
arterial blood flow which probably
decreases hypertrophy so that that's one
potential risk and then the other one is
the this is less a bad thing happening
and more just possibly preventing a good
thing happening there's some evidence
showing that the positive vascular
adaptations that can occur after
resistance training may not occur after
resistance training with blood flow
restriction because like even though
you're only trying to cut off venous
blood flow that is still affecting the
rate at which arterial blood flow can
get in so you have less shear stress on
your arteries so you have like smaller
positive arterial adaptations so again
like that's that's not a bad thing like
it's not deteriorating vascular health
but it may lead to smaller improvements
than you would otherwise see yeah and
that's one reason that I get a little
nervous about just kind of prescribing
it to somebody if I'm not there is that
certainly you want to avoid any kind of
arterial occlusion
and unless you have you know a very
sensitive pressure cuff and ideally a
Doppler ultrasound to check it's
tremendously hard to ensure that a
client's gonna do that effectively so
like I'll do it myself
sometimes to get around injury stuff but
it's it's very annoying to apply the
cuffs and there's a lot of uncertainty
there yeah and what I was gonna say when
I so I got an ACS M like student grant
to do the study that that I have
published and when you get one of those
grants you have to go to like a CSM
headquarters and be trained on how to
use this cuff and like this that you
that are is used in all these studies
we'd like this fancy blood pressure cuff
that like there's like a pressure that
you have to when you put the cuff on
someone's leg initially there's a
pressure that you have to have an app
just for like the tightness of the band
and then you inflate it to another
pressure and there's it that's what
everyone uses it's the catsuit cuff and
so we actually had to go get trained for
like half a day I'm how to use it when I
got my grant and so yeah there's there's
definitely concern with what is someone
actually doing in the gym you know how
tighter they wrap in things yeah now
another aspect of the research you've
done is the body building stuff now
you've done your part of at least one
case study I've seen and part of the the
recommendation papers that came out with
Helms and a bunch of other co-authors so
what was your ambition of kind of making
that transition from just being like a
hobbyist bodybuilder toward let's
actually put some of this on the books
and getting get involved with the
research side of things yeah I mean I
think it started when I was dieting for
my my shows in 2012 we realized that
there really wasn't a whole lot of data
out there one it one of the other guys
who was a grad student in the lab he's
not a bodybuilder or anything but he and
I were just kind of talking and you know
we're like I don't know what's out there
for research I'm like because he was
like all bodybuilding contest prep might
not be that great for you
there any research on it and we kind of
started looking and a lot of what was
out there at the time was you know
bodybuilders have psychological issues
their steroid use and bodybuilding and
you know you're basically to die if you
take steroids but you know I mean like
that's what you got when you looked in
PubMed there were a couple old case
studies but they were from like the late
80s early 90s it was a lot of the old
school kind of bro methods none of the
people in those studies usually were
drug free so there was you know
confounders there and so we just did a
case we just went to our advisor and
said hey can we do a case study on my
prep and so we like outlined what we
were gonna do and he's like as long as
it doesn't cost any money and you're not
using space when other funded studies
are there you can do it so every Sunday
morning it's every other every two weeks
on Sunday morning at 7 a.m. we did like
2 hours of testing because that's when
you know that I mean that's when you can
get in the lab when nobody else is there
right yeah yeah so we did we published
that study and then somewhere around
that time Eric was talking about trying
to he approached me about trying to
write some recommendation papers I was
like yeah I mean it would need some more
science-based stuff in the bodybuilding
world because people were doing a little
bit more science-based stuff you know by
that point by like 2012 ish you know
what I mean they're starting to be more
he started was starting to be less
brownie more science-based approaches in
the bodybuilding world but there really
wasn't a lot of science you could go
back and actually cite or say yeah this
is why this is probably a good idea to
do and so yeah we approached me with
that and yeah we worked on some of those
and it's just kind of growing from there
so you got a couple other I get a couple
other papers and the works also
bodybuilding related but I don't know
how quickly either of those are moving
so you're just gonna leave us with a
teaser both both papers I have in the
works that I'm a co-author on another
bodybuilding related are our far from
publication stage at this point so on
that note I do want to ask you a few
things that are kind of bodybuilding
focused when I you know we've talked
bodybuilding before we both presented it
think lanes camp like yeah years ago and
I vividly remember talking to you about
peak week in the back of the van yeah so
we were there on our own volition we
weren't by any means stuck in demand or
found it was we were just sitting in the
van it's fine but we were talking about
peak week I know you do the the the high
high carb backloading at least back then
you did is that's no your kind of me
personally yes as far as my clients
there are a few maybe that can get away
with it but it you know I mean it
depends on the person I would say okay
so so with you don't have that approach
for all clients you kind of go on
case-by-case basis yeah I mean you're
you're not so peaking I mean there's
some science you can pull into peaking
you know like it's probably a good idea
to eat carbs and salt and water if
you're gonna if you want to fill out you
know but as far as when you actually
load someone's carbs throughout the week
to fill glycogen stores and how you go
about that there's a lot there's I mean
it's I don't know how you do research it
to begin with and there's just a lot of
individual variability there are some
people where you give them a high carb
they say late and crap they have a high
carb day where their cards are double or
something like that
some people look watery the next day and
two days later they look really good
some people look really good the next
day
so those two people are gonna need
different peaking approaches that you
know the person who looks watery the
next day it looks pretty good two days
later is gonna want their you know that
they would do terrible having Friday be
their highest carb day for a Saturday
show where someone who looks great the
next day after a lot of carbs you want
to load them hardest Friday probably and
then even then within that I mean you
have the you have the question of is
this someone I can deplete and try to
load really hard and get glycogen super
compensation or is it someone I just
want to do like something more gradual
like a front loader mid load or back
load or something like that
yeah and just so people listening are
aware when we say front load we mean
you're adding carbs earlier in this so
if it's a Saturday show you might start
as early as Monday and start increasing
carbs and a back load would be basically
fried like
the day before or two days before kind
of yeah or even or even building from
like Tuesday Wednesday huh you know what
I mean and yeah building up to that if
what you're doing something more gradual
but yeah and then you know do you know
so you know those are approaches I would
use I would use something like a front
loader a mid loader a back load without
any sort of depletion if I didn't have
time to test you know things out even
with a back load I even if it's a
gradual when I oftentimes like to test
it because you have less room for air
you know if you're if you're loading
someone with their highest carb intake
on Friday you better be sure that they
look better afterwards
because there's no time to fix that yeah
and so I think that's the biggest thing
with peaking is if you're gonna do
something if you want to do something
aggressive so I mean there is some
evidence that granted it's from cyclists
who they glycogen deplete through you
know a lot of exercise and cycling they
glycogen deplete them they fill them
with carbs really quickly and you see
greater glycogen storage than if they
had not depleted for a short period of
time you can store a little bit extra
glycogen if you want to try to do
something like that where you deplete
and then you load really hard in those
last days like when I wrap it back
loaded into my shows I was doing upwards
of a thousand grams of carbs Friday I
actually had a guy last year do a
thousand seventy or 1375 grams of carbs
Friday and I still he still could have
probably gotten more full so you know
you if you're gonna do something like
that
you gotta test it ahead of time there
you should not be going in blind your
last week and hoping it works how does
one do that is it just like an IV of
honey so when I so basically it's gotta
be so if you're gonna get a thousand
grams of carbs down in a day it and
you're gonna do it in a way where you
don't have a food baby because you've
got a stuff on stage the next day it's
got to be stuff that you digest absorb
quickly also if you're thinking about
you want to fill glycogen stores quickly
part of if you're doing a rapid back
load for example if you're depleting and
trying to take advantage of trying to
get some glycogen super compensation it
has to happen quickly like oatmeal would
probably be a really bad idea you know
you're gonna want to stick to thing
usually stick to things like either
drinking some of the sugar candy you
cereal not high-fiber kind rice cakes
white potato you know things like that
are things that I would normally use
things that you like I said that even
like white rice wouldn't be a terrible
source you know something that you'd be
able to eat and it'd be able to digest
absorb quickly and then on top of that
keeping protein and fat lower so if you
can keep protein fat and fiber lower
that'll help me know that because all of
those slow digestion and absorption so
you're just trying to get it in as
quickly as you can
yeah no Gregg we got to stop bringing
scientists on because I what I was
hoping would happen is I say Peter
defend huge carb intakes and back load
and everyone and I have I'm you have
notes and notes here just pages of me
taking him to task on it and he gives a
very nuanced to take like that and
frankly I don't know what to do with it
I really wanted a cathartic release cuz
when I tried you know a really high carb
load into a show I looked miserable yeah
yeah I'm trying to a second time and I
looked miserable again and so like I had
two seasons where I did a show that I
didn't care about and then my show after
and I always looked better at the show I
didn't care about because I didn't
bother peaking for it yeah so I was
hoping that we could really I was kind
of hoping to get tempers to flare a
little bit but haha we are agreeing so
so you're so you're argumentative
strategy was going to be to counter his
point with an anecdote cuz I mean right
yeah that sounds pretty strong to me but
just just verifying here this is how
scientists do things honestly though it
speaking it a lot of it is antidote you
know at this point like there there's
not like it this is how you do it
there aren't studies and I don't even
know how you would conduct them you
probably have to do like some measure I
mean what would your outcomes be
probably some measure of like muscle
girth like you know quat you know like
how circumference maybe like daksa I
don't you know what I mean like why
couldn't it just be subjective like just
yeah like a panel of 10 bodybuilding
judges
and have people try two or three
different peaks black their faces out
and then just have the judges rate what
looks best yeah I mean because that's
alt that's ultimately the outcome
measure you're interested in right
absolutely absolutely the judges think
you look like and the hard thing though
is I could give to people the same like
approach and it'd be good for one and
terrible for another like Eric is
someone who if he has a really high carb
day the day before a show looks worse I
actually have a time I mean I've posted
before the time course of my backload
and how much better I looked over like
the 30 hours of loading carbs going into
prejudging it you know what I mean it
looked really good that's the best I
ever looked I got I definitely saw a
super compensation because it's more
full than I was ever able to get not
depleting and aggressively loading like
that but that's not the approach I would
use for most people you know I often
times my favorite approach and what I
found to be really effective for you
know some of the classes that don't have
as an extreme of the look like bikini
for example the the looks not as extreme
you wouldn't ever wrap it back load a
bikini client and so a lot of time for a
class like that if you can have them
ready a few weeks early and just start
raising their food going into the show
so let they fill out a little bit I've
actually had multiple occasions where I
did nothing for a bikini client during
peak week they just ate as they normally
would throughout the week because we've
worked their food back up and they're a
little fuller and I've had clients when
Pro cards and pro shows without any real
change that final week in like a bikini
division it typically though if you get
into the more muscular more extreme look
divisions you're gonna want to do a
little bit more than that but but yeah
it doesn't have to be you know it just
even being ready early and kind of
reversing into your show can be a great
option for some of these some people I
tell you what Peter we can plan that
study and what we'll do is use the that
old fat free mass index paper from the
mid 90s we'll just print pictures and
say which pictures looked better and
then they take us to task on that will
say fine here's all the ultrasound
measurements and the body water
measurements but there is precedent and
I say we go for it boldly yeah yeah and
I mean I think like I said the hardest
part with a study like that is that I
know that there'd be one answer just
because two people can do the exact same
thing it works really well for one and
really terribly for another variability
can be measured yeah so you just collect
the enough like other measures of things
that might potentially predict what
people will do better or worse with and
then just P hack your way to significant
results like that's yeah just just go
mining for significance yeah I just I
just want to kind of make a note that
I'm not participating in that part of
the conversation I got nothing to do
with that mess
now Peter do you work with any strength
and power athletes weight lifters power
lifters anything like that
yes um mostly on the nutrition side of
things but a little bit of programming
but mostly the nutrition side because I
don't know if you've come across this
but I'm sure you probably have but a lot
of times people in the strength sports
when they go to cut it's just they have
they have all these ridiculous ideas or
ridiculous methods they think they need
to do and oftentimes they drop a bunch
of strength and lose muscle mass and
whatnot and so just simply taking a more
reasonable approach to a cut to you know
make weight for a meet for example they
can hold on to a lot more strength so do
you use any of your kind of your peak
week type techniques for depletion and
reloading do you use any of that stuff
in strength athletes that are trying to
kind of do like a water cut before I
mean I I haven't really a lot of what
I've used actually somewhat along those
lines is those switching to lower
residue food sources like the last day
just like how a bodybuilder the day
before a show you're probably not going
to want to be pounding the broccoli and
oatmeal and stuff that we keep you know
with a bodybuilder the last day before a
show typically regardless of peaking
method I usually recommend low residue
foods you know rice cakes cereal not the
high fiber kind you know potatoes brown
or white rice and stuff like that that
isn't gonna send your gut and cause a
bunch of distension but I think Greg
didn't you guys review a study and mass
on on low residue foods before a meat
you saw like because they sound like a 1
to 2 percent drop
and you do see that in practice too in
body weight theoretically so the the
paper was actually on water loading but
most of the most of the decrease in
weight that they saw in that study was
probably attributable to the low residue
foods that they had people on for like
the entire week that they were doing the
study so what they saw was like a pretty
quick to three kilo drop in weight and
in kind of a plateau and then with
actual water manipulation that calls
like another kilo drop give or take yeah
so yeah the the paper was theoretically
about water manipulation but most most
of the results are probably attributable
to the to the low residue foods they had
people on yeah and I I would say you
know you see that in practice if someone
eats a low residue foods like Thursday
Friday or just Friday even by Saturday
morning their weight does drop a decent
amount just from not having as much
volume and their GI tract so and I mean
that's basically you know that way I
like that approach too because usually
then on Friday or the day before your
meat you can still eat your normal carb
intake or calorie intake are very close
to it and still see that drop make your
weight class and not have a significant
drop in performance that you might see
if you you know significantly pullback
intake the last few days or did
something crazy with water especially if
you get to extremes you know those last
few days and especially if you have a
two-hour weigh-in that changes the game
compared to a 24-hour way and also so if
somebody's weighing in I guess the way
I'd phrase this question is you said as
long as you're not going to extreme how
extreme do you consider to extreme when
it comes to like a short-term weight
manipulation for a competition I don't I
don't know if there's an um I would I
would say it may vary from person to
person again I treat the last week
before powerlifting meet almost like the
last week before a bodybuilding contest
if you're going to do something crazy
you need to test it ahead of time and so
I think if you want to try something and
say yeah can I drop I don't know eight
pounds in the last week through a
combination of whatever I'm doing you
know combination of low
food water manipulation low residue you
know low calories low carbs whatever you
know can I drop eight pounds the last
week and still perform well after it you
know when I meet with the two our way
and you may want to test that out you
know ahead of time to make sure that hey
I actually can do this like one I can
actually make weight if I do this and
two I can actually still perform well
because you know if not you may want to
get a bit closer
you know diet down have your weight
you're walking around at be a bit closer
so you don't have to do as much that
last week yeah Greg have you ever done
like a short-term weight manipulation
going into a meat or have you just
always tried to be stronger the the only
time I did it was the last meat I did
actually drop from I mean it wasn't a
huge cut but I I cut from about 253 to
239 in about four days
how'd you how'd your performance react
to that change so it's hard to say
because the as I was doing that I also
injured my back pretty badly in the
dumbest way possible I I slipped and
fell awkwardly on some black ice and so
I mean the meat didn't go particularly
well but it would have gone poorly
regardless so yeah who knows he Peter I
don't know if you remember this back in
the day but one time a very notable
bodybuilder got injured going into a big
competition yeah and the claim was I
slipped on ice and nobody thought that
they had just done something stupid
drug-related or yeah yeah something cuz
there was a toy as a torn quad right and
yeah yeah I was either a quarter a
tricep or something yeah but yeah he was
like I slipped on ice and everybody's
like dude no you trained like a maniac
yeah he probably snapped yourself up in
the gym I'm not accusing Greg of
anything but repulse Owens so for for
what it's worth Ben bench still went
well squad squad I just had my opener
deadlift I pulled what I needed to to
win but I still bench like 474 or
something like that so like strength
felt like it was there and it's just I
couldn't load my back yeah it's also
really upsetting that your numbers are
so high a lot of people don't know that
Greg doesn't lift weights it's just not
a part of his life and hasn't been for
some time and if we did a combined meet
right now me and Peter versus Greg I
think it'd be more competitive than
Peter or I would like to admit and Peter
that's mostly my fault I'm not putting
that blame on you
it's gonna say I don't do much and I
never hit much of the big three recently
side yeah yeah I'm more trying to like
tone right now you know what I mean I'm
trying to tone up I was like the closest
to the big three I've hit recently or
what I've been hitting recently probably
be hack squat machine are tiel's and
dumbbell incline probably be the closest
equivalent yeah
well we can work those into the meat now
Peter from the very outset of this
interview you've been trying to play the
role of the used car salesman so I'm
finally gonna indulge that inner desire
and I do want to ask you a couple things
about your book that you've been
peddling so hard so you've got a new
book out with Cliff Wilson right yep I
mean it's available currently right I
March 17th is the release date I think
it's available on Amazon April second so
I don't know when this podcast to be up
but yeah it's very close so st. Patty's
Day celebrate with a lovely book so I
guess that my questions about the book
are first of all who is this for is it
for the coach for the athlete for the
general population who's trying to get
into bodybuilding really any combination
I would say you have to probably have
some background in lifting weights like
you know this isn't gonna tell you this
is how you benchpress this is how you
squat that's not really in there but
assuming you have some background on how
to lift this would definitely be a good
guideline to answer a lot of the
questions going into
for show there's probably stuff in here
too that even experienced competitors
could learn or try out to potentially
improve as well so I think it could be
either and same with coaching but it'd
be probably a good book for coaches as
well cuz I mean cliff and I we talk
about science and it's science-based but
there's also some stuff in there where
it's like we do this and we think this
but you know we're not really sure but
this is what we see yeah and I like that
especially when it comes to body
building there's so much extrapolation
and conjecture and a lot of times people
in the evidence-based community don't
want to go there because they feel like
they are anchored to PubMed and in
reality a body building book that
doesn't kind of approach some of those
topics is an incomplete book in my
opinion you know we're just really
getting the ball rolling with this body
building research thing so I'd like that
you go there and just clearly label it
and say we're gonna kind of overextend a
little bit and branch out and here's
what we're thinking so I really like
that yeah I think a lot of people are
just too intellectually cowardly to
publicly state their opinions I think
that's a lot of it yeah and that is a
hot take yeah and I mean I think we we
do a good job of saying well here's what
we you know and a lot of our I like the
way we have things laid out and
obviously I should I wrote you know a
co-author play yeah like we have things
laid out in the fact that it's not like
here's all the science so this is what
you should do it's more like this is
what you should do and here's some
science to support that you know what I
mean like we wrote it more in the way of
this is what you do and with like
references to support it if that my own
yeah so so if you were kind of because
there's a lot out there to read in the
realm of body building so if you were to
kind of distill it down into a message
of why you're a book like what about
your book makes it special such that I
should read it
what's kind of your like little pitch or
tagline for what separates your book
from the others and then it's kind of a
corollary what is
what are five things wrong with all of
the other books out there if you could
use names of the authors of the ideal oh
man I'll stick with the first question
so what makes our book unique probably
two things one is when we set out to
write this we set out to write something
that really could help competitors
answer more questions than just how to
eat and how to train so yeah there's a
nutrition chapter yeah there's a
training chapter but we cover a lot of
other stuff we we have an entire chapter
on picking a show right of loss because
let's be honest that is the number one
issue most you know most number one
reason most people don't place as well
as they should they just simply don't
take long enough to diet meaning they
either diet too fast and sacrifice
muscle or they just don't get lean
enough so yeah I would say you know the
other stuff that we talked about posing
tanning what to do after the show you
know we talked a number different peak
week strategies what happens on show day
all of those type of things so it's more
than just here's how you eat and train I
mean that's in there too but it's it's
more than that um so that's one thing
the other would be that writing it with
cliff I I think it was he was probably
the best person I could have written
this book with because we agree on most
things but our backgrounds are very
different you know I come from more
academic I have the traditional academic
background he doesn't he's very
self-taught a lot of experience and
let's be honest he's probably the most
successful bodybuilding prep coach
you're very close to it out there but I
think the fact that we agree on most
things but we came to those conclusions
I you know differently you know what I
mean it makes the book much more
complete it's better than either of us
could have done on our own perfect yeah
and so you know you are the academic who
much like me you decided to you you have
that academic background but you decided
to work in a bathrobe and slippers every
day and
disappoint your family yes so what led
to that why are you working in your
bathrobe now instead of in a university
office yeah so when I started my PhD I
thought I wanted to be a professor at
like a like a smaller teaching school
because I get my bachelor's and master's
at a more it was just you know a
master's level university more teaching
focused and I was like yeah I'd love to
come back here and teach and you know as
I you know as I started going into
getting further further into my PhD I
start having more and more people asked
me hey can you help me prep for whatever
show and when there are friends I would
just kind of help them out for nothing
or free or whatever and they would do
our ride and you know they would start
you know they do well and they would
tell other people and I started getting
all these people inquiring I didn't know
and so eventually that led to me kind of
you know forming my LLC has started
working with some of those people I
didn't know and it just kind of grew by
the time I was done and basically by the
end I was basically working a full-time
job coaching and trying to finish my PhD
at the same time but I really enjoyed
the coaching side of things and I was
really really burnt out on academia and
research by the end and and all the
hoops and whatnot that you have to jump
through there and coaching I enjoy it
and so yeah I just kind of kept it
rolling with it and you know we're what
three and a half years since I've
defended and it's so far so good so you
said that there are hoops to jump
through in academia yeah well this is
yeah interesting
well Peter we really appreciate your
time man and we've had a at least I've
had a very good time speaking with you
I'm sure Greg would concur thanks so
much for coming on and for sharing your
experience with us and selfishly I am
stoked that you're doing what you're
doing putting out this really applied
information it's it's nice to have you
in the real world and outside of the
academic silo so we can learn more from
you so thank you for coming on thanks
for taking time for us and if you're
listening certainly check out Peters
book I have not read it yet because he
hasn't sent me a copy I don't understand
why at the time of the recording here I
don't
even have a physical copy in my hand yet
so that's a suitable excuse but I based
on what Peters done in the past I'm
certain it's gonna be a very very solid
book and cliff Wilson as well it's hard
to find a more experienced coach than
cliff
so check out Peters website check out
his book and Peter thanks so much for
coming on yeah thanks for having me hey
Peter where can I work in the people
find you oh yeah
so my website fit body physique comm I'm
on Instagram at fit body physique or I'm
on Facebook also just as myself so any
of those would be good places to find me
cool deal yep I go everything Eric said
thank you so much for for taking your
time and coming on this has been great
yeah thanks for having me
all right everyone thank you for
listening and we are signing off thanks
for listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it visit stronger by science
com to check out the products and
services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you